LETTER TO LAUD THEIR
RESILIENCE AND THEIR RESOLVE.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU, TRACE.
APPRECIATE IT.
RYAN IS A FORMER SNIPER AND
FIREARMS ATTORNEY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE COMING TO
THE MARCH ARE UPSET ABOUT THE
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS AND MAYBE
THEY HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT THE
AGENDA.
PEOPLE ORGANIZING HAVE A CLEAR
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO DO
DIFFERENT THINGS AND I WANT TO
RUN SOME BY YOU TO GET YOUR
RESPONSES WHETHER THEY WOULD
WORK.
THE PRIMARY ONE IS TO BAN THE
AR-15, OR THE CATEGORY OF THE
SEMI-AUTOMATIC RIFLES.
WOULD THAT HAVE STOPPED THE
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS WE THIS -- WE
HAVE SEEN?
>> NO.
CRIMINALS DON'T OBEY LAWS.
BANNING INANIMATE OBJECT WILL
NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE MARYLAND
SHOOTING YESTERDAY DIDN'T
INVOLVE AN AR-15.
VIRGINIA TECH, THEY USED
PISTOLS.
FORD HOOD MASSACRE USED BIS
TO.
9/11 THEY USED BOXCUTTERS.
THE TOOL IS NOT THE PROBLEM.
LOOK AT THE AUSTIN BOMBINGS WE
SOLVED TODAY.
BECOMES ARE ALREADY ILLEGAL.
IT DIDN'T STOP BOMBINGS FROM
HAPPENING.
>> Tucker: WE KNOW BECAUSE I
SAW IT ON CNN ALL WEEK
HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES ARE
THE CORE PROBLEM.
WHEN WE BAN THOSE THIS WILL
END, RIGHT?
>> OF COURSE.
OF COURSE.
BECAUSE DURING THE ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN THAT STARTED IN
1994 AND SUNSETTED IN 2004, IT
DID NOTHING TO STOP VIOLENT
CRIME.
TODAY'S LEVEL OF VIOLENT CRIME
ARE 50% LOWER THAN THEY WERE
AT THE PEAK IN 1997 RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE SAME BAN
THAT BANNED THOSE SO-CALLED
DANGEROUS HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINES.
>> Tucker: THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
PLACES WITH THE STRICT GUN
CONTROL LAWS ARE MUCH SAFER.
I KEEP HEARING THAT.
>> SO ONE OF THE THINGS I LOVE
ABOUT THE FEDERALIST SYSTEM WE
CAN LOOK AT, YOU KNOW,
SOCIETIES, LITTLE CITIES OR
THE STATES AND EXPERIMENT WITH
THE LAWS OR WAYS OF DOING
THINGS.
I THINK BEFORE WE HAVE SERIOUS
GUN CONTROL LEGISLATIVE WE
SHOULD LOOK AT CHICAGO AND SEE
HOW IT IS WORKING THERE.
>> Tucker: HOW IS IT
WORKING?
HAS IT STOPPED?
THEY THIS BANNED SHOOTINGS
THERE SO THERE ARE NO MORE
SHOOTINGS.
>> SOLVED THE PROBLEM, RIGHT?